Першими спробами я дійсно був розчарований —
скільки я злився, скільки яєць перебив.
Не один кошик яєць перебив, але не здався.
Тут три яйця: гусине, в ньому різне куряче,
а в курячому — різне перепелине.
І теж секрет для багатьох людей:
як воно туди потрапило?
Мене медіа чомусь прозвали «волинським
Фаберже» або «українським Фаберже»,
хоча я в зовсім іншому стилі працюю.
Фаберже працював по кам'яних,
дерев'яних і металічних яйцях.
Я ж працюю в традиційній українській
техніці — по шкаралупі,
тільки замість воску і фарби
я використовую метал.
Наприклад, я тут використав
по історії старовинний засов,
який використовувався
і 500, і 600 років тому.
Це простий засов, яким люди
замикали комори, хліви, і таке інше,
там свій спеціальний ключ був,
свій вигин і своя завитушка,
і нічого іншого не підходило, бо ніхто
не знав, чи воно має два міліметра чи сім.
Був простий замок,
але надійніший за ті, що зараз ламають.
Воно просто отак стоїть на склянці.
Його потрібно припідняти трошки
і провернути — і тоді ми відкриваємо.
І воно так працює на основі старовинних...
От я його засунув, назад замок поклав
і все — воно вже стоїть.
От шкаралупа —
це кальцій, кремній і крейда.
Якщо взяти по законах фізики і хімії,
шкаралупу можна тільки розчинити,
але її нереально витягнути.
Але в мене це виходить
— от, будь ласка, подивіться,
що я можу зробити зі шкаралупи яйця.
Отут є по два-три рекорди на одній сторінці.
Рекорди, які, вони говорять,
майже нереально побити.
І от зараз я відкриваю номінацію «Колекції» —
вони йдуть на всю сторінку.
Є підтвердження вже з «Книги рекордів Гіннеса»,
що аналогів у світі немає.
А реєстрація у «Книзі рекордів Гіннеса» —
це від 10 тисяч доларів.
Тож це нереально.
Це якийсь магнат...
Я знаю знайомого, який має...
Для нього 10 тисяч доларів — це ніщо.
Він є рекордсменом «Книги рекордів Гіннеса».
Він заплатив цю суму, тому що він найшвидше
без хліба, без нічого з'їв кіло сала.
І він — рекордсмен світу.
Тільки тут трошки переплутали,
що «Анатолій став інвалідом
під час служби в армії
і військових дій в Афганістані».
Доля склалася так,
що я був в Нагірному Карабасі.
Точно так само були ми,
як зараз на Донбасі «іх там нєт».
Розумієте? Отак само нас кидали,
особливо західних українців, білорусів, українців.
Нас по документах офіційно там не було.
А ті, хто там побував, хто залишився,
відчули на собі це.
У того воно закарбувалось і лишилось.
Але я це ніде стараюсь
не афішувати, не озвучувати.
Мені зараз вже потрібно
думати про дітей і здоров'я.
Тут все в пилюці. Я візьму інші окуляри.
Бо травма моя зір з'їла.
Оце дряпанка — можна дряпати.
Я показую, що можна робити з яйцем.
Один рух трохи неправильно — і вже все,
але з нього можна вирізати хороші речі.
Коли я вже оце все порізав,
в мене є спеціальні крючки —
я їх сам виготовляю зі спиць
професійних гоночних велосипедів —
там сталь дуже потужна.
І от бачите, якщо придивитися
— це є плівочка, заусениця.
І ось так тоді акуратно ту
внутрішню шкаралупу я вичищаю.
Тоді або так лишити, або підставку,
і, звичайно, покрити лаком.
Я її прозвав свого роду народною колекцією.
От яке яйце в мене стояло, наприклад, на полиці
чи виставлялось на виставках чи ще десь,
от якщо воно всім подобається —
від простого пенсіонера до дитини,
до науковця, професора, до доктора наук —
от воно зроблене таким чином,
що воно своєю енергетикою приваблює,
воно несе цей естетичний вигляд такий,
що воно подобається всім.
Якщо всі одночасно хочуть оце, значить, воно
щось має таке, що заворожує, щось несе в собі.